okay imagine this what if we could speak
every language here I am speaking
English I'm usingen an AI video
generator that translates your videos
with One Click by cloning your mouth
movements and
voice this new technology opens up a
world of possibilities so much of
culture is dependent on language while
people would grow a greater appreciation
of different cultures culture as a whole
will become more unified some of it
maybe even lost people's dating pools
would become so much bigger now that
language is no longer a barrier imagine
what technology or space travel could
look like if everyone around the world
could easily communicate with each other
what would you do if you could suddenly
communicate with everyone